hit me with that unique secret this is
not a sequel sounds like a sequel to me
what was true in season one and was
again true this season is that
there's another murderer
We Love Murder you're drawn to it one
might say
we get a bunch of new suspects and
characters look at all the people losing
their heads
all the casting is so on point the
person who was the killer I told them
that they were the killer everybody else
I didn't say one way or the other every
actor thought it was himself because
we're so seldominal we're so
self-involved like oh please be me well
I I probably did it I did it I also
killed that dude I strangled him with my
bare hands he was poisoned I poisoned
Edgar with my bare hands episode eight I
was like I know who did this I do know a
suspect when I see one man when I got to
find out who did it I was wrong this
season we decided to really push the
genres even farther you gotta waist deep
in the same dirty deal as your womb
fruit it's a fun challenge of the show
that you're not just playing a genre but
you're playing the subjectivity of the
person whose episode it is you are
madder than a Mad Hatter at a hat
habitat
it was maybe one of the most magical
acting moments of my life
I think people are gonna fall in love
with these characters while also getting
to play that game of whodunit with each
other so
okay I think we got it they're always
surprising you Lord vanilla and the
stakes couldn't be higher
[Applause]
it's everything you loved about the
first season and a bunch of new stuff